[Música]
eu queria começar fazendo uma pergunta
se a gente já sabe o que nos traz bem
estar
por que é tão difícil colocar colocar
essas coisas em prática por que é tão
difícil pôr em prática os comportamentos
que a gente já sabe que nos trazem bem
estar
eu acho que eu tenho uma pista e eu
queria contar hoje à noite para vocês a
história de como cheguei essa descoberta
meu nome é daniel barros eu sou
psiquiatra não precisa fugir
eu estou acostumado as pessoas falam que
sou psiquiatra algumas pessoas saem de
fininho também saiu correndo não ter
medo as pessoas têm um certo medo de
psiquiatra né acho que as pessoas acham
que se a gente olhar muito de perto a
gente vai descobrir você sabe o quê né
eu não sei por que eu estou aqui para
descobrir
eu não estou aqui trabalhando e pode
voltar fica à vontade eu não estou
trabalhando mas também não vem depois do
final da palestra pedir aquela
receitinha de rio o trio
eu sei que você pensou nem falou que tem
um psiquiatra que o olho já brilhou
eu vou pegar essa minha pílula não hoje
a gente está aqui pra falar de outras
pílulas de bem estar
esse bullying que a gente sofre porque o
psiquiatra 1 médico que sofre bullying e
esse bullying que a gente sofre por
outro lado até nos protege as pessoas
não tenham filla consulta
sabe aquela coisa de dar uma olhadinha
com psiquiatra não tem muitas pessoas
têm receio nem como estava dizendo com
dermato isso é mais para a famosa de um
dermatologista americano que ele foi
reconhecido na fila do mercado por uma
senhora verdadeira história e ela disse
nacional doutor fulano di tal
dermatologista ele todo o grupo lançou
eu ela olhou para os braços e assim a
pena que não tenho nada para mostrar
se não acontece com psiquiatras pessoas
não vêm mostrando os seus problemas nem
psiquiatras também nem com o
ginecologista
pelo menos não na fila do mercado agora
sendo psiquiatra eu comecei a me é
pensar nessas nesses comportamentos que
trazem o bem estar que a gente já sabe
de tanto tempo e que a gente tem
dificuldade de pôr em prática os
conselhos que as nossas avós já nos
davam e as avós dela davam para que
nossas avós eram os conselhos que as
nossas avós nos davam sempre certos como
direito não dorme tarde ver com quem
você anda conselho sempre certos tinham
que não era sempre certo que era leva
uma blusa que vai esfriar a quem sentar
então esse conselho não sei se essa
força da fé nesses conselhos mas por que
será que essas coisas são tão fáceis de
entender e tão difícil de pôr em prática
eu não conheço nada que seja mais fácil
de entender e mais difícil do que pôr em
prática o que comer bem do que dormir
bem do que fazer atividade física do que
cuidar dos relacionamentos
ele tem uma coisa que eu acho que é mais
fácil de entender mais difícil de pôr em
prática que é o código de trânsito
todo mundo defende ninguém põe em
prática e eu fico muito à vontade para
falar de trânsito porque eu dirijo mal
eu sou barbeiro então eu estou sempre
tranquilo no trânsito eu nunca passa o
stress é o causo nos outros mas esses
comportamentos a gente tem dificuldade
de pôr em prática ea ficha começou a
cair pra mim quando é eu essa história
descobrir quando eu comecei a pensar num
outro num outro contexto comecei a
pensar no que as pessoas querem
já faz quase 20 anos que o ato na
psiquiatria e depois de tanto tempo você
começa a entender o que todo mundo quer
no final das contas é que todo mundo
quer no final das contas quer se livrar
dos boletos e dos quilos extras
é o que todo mundo quer mas não é só
isso eu descobri que a gente quer mais
comecei a pensar no que a gente quer a
gente quer bons relacionamentos
a gente quer dormir melhor do que a
gente dorme
a gente quer diminuir o nosso stress ea
gente quer uma coisa e isso todo mundo
que é esse é o grande objetivo de todos
nós mesmo que a gente não saiba disso
é uma coisa que a gente não quer a gente
não é fácil a gente não quer morrer é
isso estudei bastante e descobri que não
vai dar
a morte não é uma questão de escolha a
morte é uma questão de tempo só esperar
só que tem uma coisa que é uma questão
de escolha é como a gente vive e as
escolhas que a gente faz de vida podem
mudar o tempo que vai levar pra gente
chegar a até a morte
isso pode ser estendido a gente pode
aumentar nossa longevidade
comecei a olhar essas a lista do que as
pessoas querem do que todos nós queremos
eu olhei aquela lista falei olha isso
aqui está parecendo o índice de livro de
auto ajuda
esse alívio que vende bem autoajuda
livro que vende bem mas pega muito mal
né seu motor de autoajuda eu sou eu
tenho é uma atuação acadêmica eu tenho
uma atuação da universidade de são paulo
e eu tenha bastante a reação dos meus
pares com relação a publicar um livro de
autoajuda mas eu tenho uma ideia falei
já sei vou fazer um livro de auto ajuda
baseado em evidências científicas não
pegar assim várias dicas práticas para a
felicidade pra dormir melhor para ter
bons relacionamentos para viver mais que
tenha fundamento científico procurar
pesquisas que têm o fundamento pra
colocar essas essas idéias em prática
isso diminuiu já um pouco o preconceito
dos meus pares mas o argumento
definitivo foi quando falei para eles o
seguinte gente isso aqui escrever um
livro de auto-ajuda uma possibilidade de
ajudar as pessoas no atacado porque na
clínica no dia a dia a gente ajuda às
pessoas mas eu digo que a gente ajuda no
varejo
o livro de autoajuda era uma forma de
ajudar no atacado e ainda deu o troco
com isso falei olha esse argumento
definitivo
se é pra ajudar no atacado e ainda
ganhar um troco com isso ou escrever
esse livro ou entra para a política
reclamou de deus daniel escreve logo
esse livro perto de entrar para a
política escreveu um livro de autoajuda
parecia uma coisa maravilhosa
bastante ali vá pelo menos ele não vai
entrar para a política
até porque seja pensar bem né a
literatura ea política elas são quase
que opostas do certo ponto de vista
pensa bem na literatura você consegue
ajudar muito e ganhar pouco contrário do
que acontece na política e conforme eu
fui fazendo esse levantamento um padrão
começou a surgir um padrão muito
interessante e aí que eu fui descobrir a
resposta para aquela pergunta inicial de
por que é tão difícil colocar em prática
alguns comportamentos que são
importantes para o nosso bem estar
eu comecei a ver que fosse para escrever
o capítulo de felicidade de inteligência
de dormir melhor de viver mais alguns
comportamentos eram repetitivos algumas
dicas apareciam em todos eu não
conseguia colocar nenhum capítulo porque
elas deviam deveriam aparecer em todos
os capítulos e eu fui conversando com a
minha esposa sobre isso e o livro chama
pílulas de bem estar
então essas a gente colocou fora na
conclusão como se fossem as pílulas
mágicas
as quatro pílulas mágicas que servem pra
viver mais que serve pra ficar mais
feliz que serve pra comer melhor que
serve para se relacionar bem e quais são
elas
aquilo que as nossas avós já diziam
comer melhor dormir melhor se relacionar
bem e fazer atividade física
cuidar do corpo comer de forma mais
saudável dormir o que é necessário e ter
relacionamentos significativos
isso traz um impacto em todas as áreas
da vida como se fossem verdadeiras
pílulas mágicas e aí eu me entreguei
como cientista ou pesquisador eu fiquei
intrigado mas porque elas têm em comum
pra primeiro serem tão eficazes em
tantas áreas e segundo serem tão
difíceis de pôr em prática porque é tão
fácil de entender
é tão difícil de aplicar ou de manter é
porque às vezes você começa algumas
coisas e é difícil de continuar e a
idéia que me veio que eu acho que a
resposta que a gente pode ajudar o nosso
favor
vem do descompasso
o desencontro que existe entre o projeto
original do ser humano ea forma como que
a gente vive hoje porque nós evoluímos o
nosso corpo e nossa mente foi moldada
por um ambiente muito diferente do que a
gente tem hoje em dia quando eu quero
transmitir o impacto de quão diferente é
às vezes falo para as pessoas
gente a gente evoluiu num ambiente em
que não tinha luz elétrica
tudo bem dá para se virar com o sol o
fogo não mas também não tinha água
encanada
eu sei mas também tem rio né tem chuva
não tinha colchão de bola mas o conjunto
da dor nas costas até melhor
aí eu eu termino falando a gente não
tinha wi-fi pessoa pelo amor de deus
como é difícil viver na selva
realmente não tinha e esse descompasso
entre os impulsos e a programação do
nosso corpo e aquele ambiente que a
gente vive hoje é a origem dessa dessa
dificuldade que a gente tem e colocar
esses comportamentos em prática e ao
mesmo tempo dá eficácia deles quando a
gente consegue fazer vou pegar o exemplo
da comida a gente evoluir num contexto
em que tinha pouca comida não tinhas
abundância que tem é comida que você
conseguir matar um bicho se você
conseguir encontrar uma árvore carregada
de alguma coisa era de vez em quando e
aí que você tinha que fazer quando
encontrava comida come tudo que você
conseguir de uma vez porque não sabe
quando vai ter comida de novo
quem sobreviveu para contar a história o
gozo os nossos antepassados mais vorazes
foram que sobreviveram para contar a
história e passaram para nós essa
voracidade e mais do que isso né eles
também tinham uma preferência claro o
cérebro percebendo essa escassez de
comida desenvolveu a preferência por
comidas de alto impacto energético
comidas que sejam é muito rapidamente
absorvidas por aumentar rapidamente a
nossa energia
só que o cérebro quando evoluiu assim
ele não sabia que a gente ia refinar o
açúcar e refinar farinha
então hoje nós somos pessoas vorazes
a predileção por alimentos refinados na
que são rapidamente absorvidos e sobe
muito à glicemia num contexto em que a
gente tem mercado 24 horas
geladeira cheia de livre de coxinha
delivery de brigadeiro e que já tentou
resistir a um docinho de festa de
criança sabe como o cérebro tem essa
vontade de comer essa coisa né festa
ruim é fácil festa ruim de criança de
fechado música alta apertado pouca
comida o garçom passar correndo que é
docinho que dos 52 anos se você quiser
sem correr atrás dele é como nos
antepassados caçadores-coletores você
tem que caçar o brigadeiro pra comer nas
festas ruins mas aí é fácil resistir mas
na festa boa
o garçom para na sua frente com a mãe
deixa quentin brigadeiro beijinho ele
fala quer não brigado já começa a levar
mas eu não quero eu vou resistir não
está gostoso já experimentei esse aqui
ele aponta e você começa não obrigado aí
o garçom faz o seguinte pega um pratinho
eu vou deixar aqui só caso o senhor tem
a vontade à vontade o jato foi o amor de
deus eu só não quero é difícil resistir
porque o nosso organismo quer muita
energia muito rápido
só que o nosso corpo não está preparado
para lidar com essa sobrecarga de
glicemia subindo muito rápido então isso
é um grande desrespeito para a nossa
natureza comer vegetais - açúcar -
farinha mais comidas naturais é
respeitar a nossa natureza mesma coisa
acontece com sono
no começo não tinha nem fogo domesticado
é o sol se impunha a gente ia dormir aí
dominamos o fogo já foi o homem mais
tarde veio à luz elétrica rádio tv
aí foi ficando cada vez mais complicado
dormir cedo até que alguém inventou o
youtube achei desencarnou de vista não
vou dormir mais
só mais uma palestra do ted só mais uma
manhã eu desconto ea gente nunca
desconta e essa conta chega para nós ea
gente não dorme bem e aí o nosso
organismo
desgastado a gente não dorme o
suficiente a gente engorda inclusive a
maioria das pessoas que sente que não
dorme o suficiente
é por causa do seu próprio comportamento
de procrastinação da hora de dormir
famoso e rolar pra ir pra cama
já deu para entender por que é tão
difícil também fazem atividade física
o nosso organismo que não tinha muita
energia e nos doutor de um impulso de
guardar o máximo de energia possível
então fica paradinho o tempo todo que
você conseguir mas a gente era obrigado
a sair correndo caçar matabicho fugir de
bicho construir abrigo em que a gente
era obrigado a fazer atividade física a
gente tinha de um lado o impulso de
guardar energia e de outro lado a força
a obrigação de se levantar e se mexer
o que a gente fez com a tecnologia hoje
a gente respeita religiosamente metade
desses impulsos a gente com a tecnologia
tirou toda obrigação que a gente tem de
se mexer
a gente fica paradinho o tempo todo
guardando o máximo de energia possível e
com abundância de energia que têm hoje à
nossa volta com todos esses alimentos
o resultado só pode ser obeso idade só
pode ir contra a nossa saúde e contra a
nossa longevidade
por falar em longevidade esse que é o
quarto a quarta pela mágica ela numa
palestra do ted do que é das mais vistas
de todas do nosso colega psiquiatra
robert o dinheiro e ele provou que o que
mais aumenta a longevidade e vários
índices de bem estar da nossa vida é a
presença de relacionamentos
significativos também faz todo sentido
na tribo lá atrás na selva sem colchão
de bola sem xampu anti piolhos em
shampoo anticaspa era um pelo outro
se você não cantasse o peso das minhas
costas eu ia morrer de coceira
eu defendia você defende você dividir
comigo os alimentos eu cantava os seus
piores você começava minha cabeça ficar
isolado era se colocar em risco de
morrer ou de morrer de coceira você não
ia conseguir se livrar dos seus piolhos
então a gente era do 1
instinto de buscar o próximo por isso o
isolamento ele é bastante contrário a
nossa natureza não foi isso que eu
aprendi escrevendo um livro de auto
ajuda baseado em evidências científicas
eu descobri porque é tão importante a
gente seguir os conselhos das nossas
avós porque com eles a gente vai
respeitar a nossa natureza
mas por outro lado eu descobrir por que
é tão difícil porque o nosso contexto
atual trabalha contra a nossa natureza
inicial é importante então a gente
conhecer essa natureza pra parar de
brigar contra ela e colocá lo pra brigar
nosso favor
se a gente vai comer tudo o que a gente
tem a nossa volta então vamos melhorar o
que a gente tem a nossa volta
não adianta ter um pacote de bolacha
você fala só vou comer uma o seu cérebro
não vai deixar seu cérebro programado
pra comer a inteira
a gente não é obrigado a fazer atividade
física a gente tem a tendência de querer
descansar
você vai ter que obrigar não adianta
esperar a vontade de fazer atividade
física aparecer porque ela não vai
aparecer e você vai passar a vida
inteira esperando só que como atividade
física é importante para ter uma vida
longa você vai esperar pouco tempo a
morrer logo sedentário por não ter feito
a atividade física
esse é o nosso contexto moderno ele por
um lado facilita que a gente esgar se os
nossos vínculos sociais
por outro lado as cidades nos trazem
grandes possibilidades onde trabalho
voluntário igreja clube é importante não
você está sempre cercado de gente mas é
importante você saber que você tem
alguém com quem você contar você tem um
vínculo significativo
essa tecnologia nos rouba o tempo de
sono por que não usar a própria
tecnologia para colocar limites colocar
bloqueadores de determinados tempos para
a gente dormir melhor
se a gente aprender a colocar a nossa
natureza inicial trabalhando a nosso
favor
a gente vai sofrer menos a gente vai ter
mais bem-estar porque finalmente a gente
vai conseguir seguir os conselhos das
nossas avós
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]